では よろしくお願いします
では五住盤にいたします
ナパレサンウィローマニナパレサンカタカタンアッテナヴァアヴェッケーヤカタニヤカタニチャ
このあるエピソードがありまして
サイジョンに サワッティという町にある
奥さんがいて ご婦人の方がいて
その女性の方は ある修行者をね
面倒見ているんです なんか自分の息子のように
この修行者の面倒見ているんです
名前はパーティカという名前の行者なんですね
そのサワッティ町だから
まぁブッダのことはよく知られていて
みんなほとんど仏教になっていましたし
そこでこの その家の人々やら街の人々やら
ブッダのことをよく喋っているんですね
いろんなことをお釈迦様が教えているんだと
今までとの宗教とは違いますよと
この女性も宗教に興味があるんだから
ある行者をね 自分の息子のようにずっと毎日面倒見ているんだからね
彼女もやっぱり それだったらブッダの話も聞いた方がいいんじゃないかなと思ったんです
思っても 自分が毎日お世話しているこの
まぁ別な宗教の行者がいるんだから
その方にも一緒に行きましょうと
まぁ宗教違っても お互い一緒に行って
話を聞いたりする習慣は昔はありましたからね
特に昔インドでは別にどの宗教でもお互いそれぞれ教えが違うんだけど
お互いの話を聞く 別に遠慮しないで
そこそこどんな宗教の道場にも行ったりもする
そういうことだから 何のことなく
じゃあ一緒に行きましょうということをこのパーティカさんに言うんですね
でも彼が断るんですね
行きたくないんだと そうすると
この女性は自分が一人の行者の面倒を見ているんだから
どちらかというと その人の宗教を応援しているんだからね
だから彼と一緒に行かなきゃいけないし
じゃあ一緒に行きましょうと
そういうことで彼女はこう考えるんです
この人は 私にブッダの話を聞かせようとはしないんだと
邪魔ばっかりしているんだと
別に人の話を聞いたってもいいんじゃないかと
この人は行くな 行くなとかね
一緒に行きましょうって言ってるのにとか
ではいいことをしてやるぞと
私はもうお釈迦様を自分の家に呼ぶんだと
家に呼んで話を聞くんだと
自分の息子にね お寺に行ってお釈迦様に明日食事に来るようにって言ってくださいと
[法鼓]それでこの息子も
えっと お釈迦様のところに行く前にね
自分が毎日信仰している行者がね
そこにいるんだから そちらに挨拶に行ったんです
一応礼儀ということだからね
他の宗教の方呼びますから
自分信仰している宗教の方にちょっと断らなくちゃいけないんですね
日本でも同じことやってひどい目に遭いましたけど
それでまあ その息子さんはこの行者のところに行ったんだから
あなたどこに行くんでしょうか？と言ったら
あのお釈迦様に明日にお食事にいらっしゃるようにと招待するために行くんだと
そしたらこの人は何言ってるんですか？行くなよと
やめなさいと言ったんです
そしたらこの息子は 先生
結構ですと 私はお母さんのこと怖いんだからと
お母さんのことは怖いんだよと
だから行きますよと で
この人はいい提案出すんですね
お釈迦様にするお布施とか何とかとかね
あんた持っていけばどうですか
持っていくっていうことにして
こちらに持ってきて二人で食べましょうと
いわば母親騙しましょうということなんですね
言っても息子はなかなかね
冗談じゃないんだと 母に脅されたらどうするのかと
お母さんがすごい怖いみたいですね
そうすると どうしてもお母さんの方が怖いんだから
もう行きたいんで 息子が
そうすると息子は息子にこう言うんですね
だったら まあ行ってもいいんだけど
行って招待しなさいと
しかし 住所だけ言わないでくれと
どんな村で どんな町で
どんな家でですか？その場所を言わないでくれと
なんか私にいろいろ招待されるような感じなんですね
ぜひ来てくださいと どこに行けばいいんでしょうか？わからない
それであの 行って招待して
あの別な道であっちこっちうろうろね
回り道いっぱいして みんなにわからないようにして
あんた戻ってくださいと
それでその息子は一応お母さんも怖いし
先生にも遠慮するし まあまあだからお釈迦様のところに行ってちゃんと招待して
あのアジーカさんが あの行者があの行者が言った通りに
あの自分の家があるところも教えてあげないで
まるっきり他のもう色々別なもう回り道をいっぱいして家に帰ったんで
で あの行者に報告するんです
そうすると行者がすごく喜んで
よかったよかった そこで明日お釈迦様に色々料理用意するでしょうね
二人で食べましょうと
お釈迦様来ないんだから
それでこの次の日 朝 随分早くこの行者が毎日行くんだから家に行ったんですね
そちら毎日行こうと言った通りに
そうすると この家の人々は
あの行者はまあ家のまあ後ろの方に
後ろの方に 中の方に連れて行って
まあ後ろに座ってもらったんですね
そこで家の他の人々はもうものすごい一生懸命家の前のところは綺麗にこの
あの掃除しているんですね
特にあの あの昔 あの土間ですから
そちらこのいろいろ牛の糞と土をね
練って塗り直すんですよ
塗り直すちゃうと もうかなり新しくなるし
殺菌作用もあるし お釈迦様を迎えに
だから仏教とかどうか関係なく
おそらく一生懸命お釈迦様の方が格がすごい高いんだから
それは知られているんだから
もうどんな家に呼ぶ場合はそれなりにかなり気をつけるんです
アジーカさんがそこら辺の誰かでしょう
だからごく普通に まあ同等平等に扱っちゃ
あんたそちら座ってくださいと
お釈迦様はそういうものじゃないんだから
もうカーストはすごく違うし
ものすごい上でしょうし
バラモン人よりも上でしょうし
神とか ですから そう簡単に家に呼んではいけないんですね
いろいろ準備やら いろんなことをしなくちゃいけないという習慣ですからね
で 花とかいろいろ用意して
で ブッダに まあ釈迦族にふさわしい座るところとかね
かなり品格よく用意して待ってるんです
そこでこの人々はブッダに会ったことがないんだから
とにかくわからない とにかくこのまあ一応すごい貴族の一番上の人が迎えるような感じで
まあ用意してはいる お釈迦様の住所も知っていないんだからね
でも別にお釈迦様に人の家はどこにあるか教えてあげなくたっても
お釈迦様はいつでも何でも知ってるんだから
それは全然問題にならない
それでお釈迦様がその家に行くんですよ
そこであのお釈迦様に食事をしてあげて
それからお釈迦様説法するんだから
彼女は随分喜んで もうすごい納得いける教えですからね
ブッダの教えは 最低当時の人々にでもね
だからそんなにややこしい
難しい 信仰するなくちゃいけないということでもなくて
すごいわかりやすく納得いける話ですから
彼女はすごく喜んでサードサードと言いながら
もうかなり喜んで話を聞いているんです
そうすると 後ろに家の中に座っているこの行者にはなかなか我慢できないんですね
そんなに喜んで納得しちゃうと
もうしまったなと それから当然仏教徒になってしまうんではないかなと
怒ったんです 彼女はこのの自分の信者さんがこの喜び声をね
サードサードと言うんだからね
よくわかりましたと 納得いきましたって意味ですね
サードっていうのは 怒っていきなりそちらに飛んできて
あのご婦人様方にものすごくけなして怒鳴ったんですね
死んでしまえとお前はとかね
すごいきつい言葉で で
叱って まあ怒鳴って お釈迦様にもいろいろ悪口言ってね
もう二度とまたその家に帰れなくなっちゃいますからね
家の人に悪口言っちゃうとね
逃げてしまったんですね
で このすごい立派な女性の方だから
もう こんなことを侮辱されちゃうとね
お釈迦様の前でものすごくもう恥ずかしくなっちゃって
いきなり家の中から別な宗教の行者が現れてきて
めちゃくちゃ悪口言ってもうけなしたりしちゃうとね
これすごい立場が崩れちゃうんですね
それですごく恥ずかしくなっちゃって
もう頭が混乱しちゃったんですね
今までじーっと話聞いてたんですけど
集中力が全くなくなったんです
お釈迦様の言葉はもう心に入らなくなっちゃったんです
そうしたらお釈迦様が
あんたね なんで混乱してるんですかね
もうなんか話は心に入らないみたいんですよと
集中力なくなったんじゃないの？と聞いたんですね
それでも彼女はお釈迦様
私のあの息子に怒鳴られちゃってね
もう心が混乱しちゃったんだと
息子だと思ってるんですね
あの行者が お釈迦様はね
あのね このだらしない人間の言葉
なんでそんなに気にするのかと
どうでもいい連中の話は別にどうでもいいでしょうと
そんなに気にするなよと
気にするべきは自分の行為だけではないかと
ということで まああんまりいろいろ
言われたっても 別に自分のことをやってくださいと
五途で非難っていうのはあまりあれですけど
仏教ではね 人の非難は聞きますけど
聞きなさいとは言ってますけど
だからといって 何でもかんでも人の世間の目を気にすることは良くないんですよ
理性のある 心優しい 人のことを心配する
真面目に物事を言う そういう立派な人の批判なら
すごくありがたく聞かなくちゃいけないんですよ
どうでもいいの ろくでもない人がもうガチャガチャガチャガチャものすごい大騒ぎして言ってますよ
別に気にする必要ないんです
だからこの人にいろんなものを言うのは
この大体もう一番質の悪い人間なんですよ
自分にも人格はないし
物事は判断できないし
もう自分の精神的に混乱しているんだから
もう言いたい放題人にものを言う
あんたはこうしなさい
これはダメではないか
あれはダメではないかと
そういう場合は必ずと言ってる人が一番大きい問題を持ってるんですよ
それで世間はもうみんなにあれも言われる
これも言われるということで
自分から生き方はカイロを変えるするんですよ
それがうまくとんでもないことですよ
信頼もできない 道徳もない
出来手もない 人格もない
責任も持たない いい加減な人を言う
何に何か言われたんだからといって
それにやっぱり気をつけなことは気をつけなくちゃと自分に戒めると
自分の指導者って誰ですかね
あなたらしない連中でしょうに
聞く必要はないんですよ
それはもうなんかあんたすごい頑固でしょうとか言うかもしれない
頑固じゃないんでしょ
頭がいい良いだけなんです
だからまあわかりやすく言えば
私にはいろいろアドバイスしようとして大失敗してる
そういうわけには聞かないんですよ
だらしない人の話は 責任のある
物事をちゃんと考える人に何か言ったら
すぐもうその場で聞く
だから口があるんだからといってね
喋ってるんだからといって聞く必要ない
これは大事なポイントなんですよ
だから世の中で我々生きている場合は
かなりいろんなことを言われる
言われることは気にするべきかないかということはね
その言ってる人の人格によって判断しなくちゃいけないんですよ
それでだいたい世間は逆にうるさく言う人の話は聞く
だから世間の生き方とは
いつでもブッダが推薦する生き方は大体反対ですよ
普通我々生きている社会というのは
頭の悪い人が言うことだなら必ず聞く
信頼できない人を言うことなら必ず聞く
無責任で何でも意見をしゃべる人だったら
その人の意見は聞くと
おしゃべり屋でうるさい人だったら結構売れるんですよ
いろいろテレビでもね
総論回やらね いっぱい
まあもう何でしたっけ
あれはワイドショーやらね
もうあれ決まってる 何人かがどんなテーマにも同じグループ画でぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃぺちゃしゃべる
そこまで知ってるのかと
ただもう何かもうおかしいことを言うんだから
もうお金払って それで食べてるだけ
でも聞く人々の場合はね
みんなそれに乗るんだからね
それは良くないんですよ
だから人の話を聞くならば
もう本当に物事を考えて
すごい責任を持ってしゃべっているのか
またその人は相手のことを聞いてる人々のことを本当に心配しているのかというね
そこは大事なんですよ
だから自分のことを心配しているならば
自分の幸せを願っている人であるならば
自分の幸福繁栄を願っている
その上 理性のある人であるならば
その人の話は必ず聞くべきなんです
そうでなければ ああそうですかと
それで終わっちゃえばいいんです
あれ なんか昔 あのエピソードというか
言いそっかな エピソードもありますね
あの ある あんまり覚えてないんですけどね
何でしたっけ？ある父親と息子がこの自分の家にロバがいてね
このロバを売りましょうと
売ってお金いくらか儲かりましょうと言って
マーケットにロバを連れていく
マーケットいたっても昔だからかなり距離があるんです
息子と二人でロバを連れて
三人でもう苦労しながらもうかなり疲れている
そうするとある人が来て
お前二人は何てバカですかと
歩いて疲れてるでしょうと
ロバもいるのに なんで乗っていけないのかと
なるほど それも一理あると言って
父親が息子をロバに乗せたんですね
じゃあ君乗りなさいと
そこでまあ行く で またそこでまた一人一人が来る
なんて失礼なことですかと
年取った父親が歩いてるのに
若い息子がさくさくとロバに乗っていくっていうこと
とんでもないと言ったら
そういえばそうですね
息子は若くて元気で 私は年寄り
体が弱いです だからこれはよくない
じゃあお回りなさいと言って父親が乗ったんです
もうちょっともうちょっとでまだ歩くと
また一人の人がいる 何たる父親ですかね
自分だけ楽々に 息子が苦労して歩いてるのに
それって父親やることかと
言うと怒られたんです
ああ なるほど 意味がある
言っていることは では君も乗りなさいと
二人で乗ったんです また歩けるで行くと
また人が来て あんた二人はね
こんなロバの上に二人でも乗って
なんていう動物いじめですかと
優しさってのは一欠けらもないんですかと
ロバはすごく疲れてるでしょうにと
言ったら やっぱり二人乗っちゃうとロバにはこれ大変な荷物だからね
あ なるほど そういえばそうなんですよと
ロバ疲れてるんだと 動物をいじめるなと言ったんだからね
じゃあ二人でロバを運びましょうと
で ロバ運ぶ場合は 動物運ぶ場合は
この後ろの足と前の足を結んで
間に棒を入れて そこで背負って担がなくちゃいけないんですね
それでロバを逆さまにしたって
二人で担いで持っていくんですよ
ロバ歩かなくても済みます
で またもう一人の人が来てね
まだ馬じゃないか それはもう足があるんだからね
歩かせちゃえばいいです
なんで運ぶんですかと
動物を もうなんて愚かな
見ればすごい愚かなことでしょうね
あ そう言えば まあそうですねと
またロバを下ろして また足を外して
またロバを歩かせると
そうするとまたあの同じ順番が返ってくるでしょ
だからバカの話聞くなよっていうことなんです
とにかくそのエピソードで言うのは
おそらく皆さんも子供の頃
そのエピソードを読んだことがあると思います
もう私は言わないで知ってるのかというと
見え張って知りませんって言うんだからね
まあ一応今は思い出すと思います
だからこの 人の意見に対して仏教徒はどんな態度をとるのかという答えなんですね
いつでもまあ 何でもかんでも聞くわけじゃないし
だからといって頑固というわけでもない
真理にのっとって 理性にのっとって
ちゃんと言うことなら聞く
それ以外は別にまあ聞く必要はない
そこを守っているんだから
仏教も守られていますよ
例えばイスラム教だったら
絶対いかなる場合でも他宗教の人とも本当に喋ってはいけないんですよ
でもそこまでは厳しくは言わないで喋ってもいいんだけど
まあ人間なつかされてないんですからね
勉強してはいけない 他の宗教の人は喋ることを絶対聞いてはいけない
これ絶対的に聞くなかれという
もう法律で決まってる
宗教の決まりは イスラムの国だったら法律でもあります
ですから あの他の誰かの話でも聞いちゃうと
この法律を犯したことになって
もう裁判所なんです すごい怖いんです
そういうわけで イスラム教になった人はもうもうそれっきりで
別な宗教に浸透するということはありえないんです
できるんだから そこでもう
もしかすると殺される可能性もあるし
あるいはもうもう年とか何とかとか刑でしょうし
鞭で打たれるでしょうし
もう裁判もないんだからね
この宗教家がこの人がこういうことしましたって言ったら
それで判決出たんですよ
弁護 弁解もできない それも禁止
だから普通の裁判制度だったらね
まあそんなに気にしなくたってもいいんですけど
それもないんです  宗教警察みたいなグループがいるんだからね
それで私にもイスラムの人々というのは
我々の宗教の人々は誰一人も他の宗教の浸透しませんと
このだらしない宗教だから
みんなお互いに宗教を変えたりするんだよ
イスラム教になったらなったで
誰もそこの宗教から出ていかないぞと
それまたもう話違うでしょうにと言いたいんだけど
ちょっと待って あんたの話違うでしょうと
あんた方はこうやって人を脅して禁止しているのではないかと
いえいえ 私にはあなたの話を聞く聞いてはいけないんだと
そんな話は聞きませんよと
それで断るんです 私の反論も
スリランカでですから
身の経験はないんです
スリランカではそんなに宗教間で喧嘩することはないんだから
一応いろいろ話し合ったり
論争したりはする で 仲良くはやります
だから いえいえ あなたの話は聞く聞きませんよと
いきなり私のものです
それで話は終わっちゃうんですね
言いながらまたお寺に来る
いつは何か自分の宗教はよく説得できると思っているでしょうね
それでこの まあそういう脅しで殺し殺すというね
脅しで地獄に落ちるという脅しで
あの他のことを勉強するなよと
これのみ真理だと信仰しなさいと言って
それで宗教を広げたっても大したしゃれになりませんよ
で ブッダの話をわかっている人っていうのは
だいたいそう簡単に他の宗教に入れることはできないんです
仏教はわかってない ただ伝統的に仏教の家督で生まれただけの連中は宗教変えますけど
金のために 女のためにとかね
で それ時点ではすごく何かあの人はね
ただの金のために結婚したんじゃないか
宗教変えてとかね いうだけでね
どうったことはないんです
すごい難しいんですよ
いくらお金あげてあなたの面倒は見ますよとかね
あなたの教育も何でもやってあげますと言ったら
それはありがたく受けますけど
宗教を変えなさいと言っちゃうと
ものすごい厳しいんですよ
もうもう泣きながら私のところ何人か来たんだからね
日本に来てね いろいろ宗教組織でね
まあ日本に来て まあそういう方々のそういうのはなっていますよと
でなきゃ一人の力では来られないんだと
随分お世話になってるんですけど
それは感謝しなくちゃいけないし
でもあんな宗教はね 私に信仰しなさい
信仰しなさい言うんだけど
私はどうすればいいんでしょうかと
で 泣くんですよ 我々はね
ちょこっと日本に来たいとかね
何かちょこっと勉強したいとか
そういう欲があったんだから
こういうひどい目に遭いましたと
貧乏で国でいた方がよかったんではないかと
ある自分の上の若者がもうなんか出稼ぎとかなんかで留学来たんですけど
それまた宗教組織なんかに襲われて
その宗教浸透しなさいと
言って その後私のところに来てすごく泣いたってね
我々国いた時はお寺には全然行かなかったと
お坊さんたちも相手にしないで馬鹿にしていたんだと
そのツケが回ってきたんだと
国でもうちょこっと真面目にお寺に行って勉強していたならば
あの連中に一言葉言えたはずですよと
だから私にもお金ももう借金も全部どうでもいいんだからって言って帰っちゃったんです
国に 来る代はもう借金してくるんですよ
だって 学費やらこちらにビザのあれやら
学校の払うお金ものすごいお金ですよ
だから私にもどうすることもできんし
まあその時に感じたのは
やっぱり仏教のブッダの教えを知ってる人にとってはこれ難しいんですよ
そう簡単に ポイントは脅してないんですよ
誰も 仏教は 仏教以外の宗教を信仰したら地獄に落ちますよと全然言ってないんです
ポイントはこちらなの
誰の話聞くのかと この酒と金にしか頭のない偉い聖者の話聞くかと
ブッダの話取るのかと
どちらかと判断しなさいと
こちらに来ていろいろ浸透
宗教素晴らしいと言ったっても
性格はだらしないでしょうし
不正的なことを朝から晩までやってるでしょうに
もう金もそれはもう見えるんだからね
一緒にいると 表に出す顔と裏にする顔も全部見えてるんだからね
私はこの人の話聞くか
ブッダの話か母親の話聞くかっていうことになるんです
それも選択は決まってるんです
ある人は私にももうすごく怒ってね
なんであんた酒飲まないんでしょうかとか
それちょっとたちが悪いんじゃないかと
こちらでは平等な社会でみんな仲良く一緒にやりますよと
で 日本の社会は何一つも仲良くしないことを私は知っているし
何でも一緒にやることもしないっていうことも知ってるし
とにかく互いに信じ 憎しみばっかしなんで
それはどうでもいい話で
それはまあ置いておいて
私はまあちょっと言い方がまずかったんだからね
その方もね よく普通に意見として言ったならば大丈夫ですよ
私はそう思ってますよと
あ すいませんねと言えば
それで済みますからね
相手にも生きる権利があるんだから
そうじゃなくて どういうことですか
それはとか 日本にいるんだったら
日本人と一緒にならなきゃあかんではないかと
あ そう そういう態度で来るんでしょうかと
ただ それは一つ聞きますけどと
私は酒飲まないのは まぁブッダがお釈迦様が飲むなよと言っているんだからですよ
別にどうったことないんだと
今酒飲みなさいっていうのはあんたでしょ
だからあんたは証拠を出してくださいと
あんたブッダより頭が良くて道徳があって
すごいしっかりした人間だと
すぐ飲みますよ 今すぐ飲めますよと
私は今ブッダの言葉捨ててあなたの言葉を受けなくちゃあかんでしょうにと
それで酔い覚めちゃって
もうもうもう口も出なくなっちゃってね
すぐ出た 帰りますよと
すぐその場でも帰っちゃったんです
それどれほど人を侮辱するのかと
この連中は平気で だから侮辱したんだから返しちゃったんですよ
返す時はもう二度と人を馬鹿にしないという調子で返すんです
人は馬鹿でいいんですよ
別に 相手の尊厳を守っているならばね
私は酒飲んだ方がいいと思いますよとか
そういう冗談で それはそれでいいんですよ
別に人間同士だからね
それで私も俺が嫌いだから
酒はとかね 言っちゃえば
それでまあ仲良く物事済みますね
そうじゃないんですね
このもうけなしてやるぞと
だからこの仏教の世界では
もう人のいろんなローマ法というジジイが何か言ったって聞いて悪くないんですよ
言ってることがちゃんと論理的で
まあしっかり言ってるのかと
ではなくて その人はいつでも教会はそれを認めませんと
教会が認めなかったら自分の信者さんに言えと
なぜ世界に向かって言うのかと
例えば中絶はダメだ これはもう自分の教会ではと
ではなくて 中絶はダメというならば
一般的にやっぱり生まれてくる人間も大事に守りましょうと
生命を殺していいわけないでしょうと
と言ったら もうなるほどという納得できるでしょうね
で カトリック教の神父さんでも
時々もう恋を出しちゃって
もうまともな人だったらもう女に恋しちゃうと神父でいられませんから
やっぱり辞めたいんですよ
辞めて結婚して そこはすごい正しいでしょうに
みんな裏で隠れていろんなことをやって
信者さんに嘘を言うよりは
やっぱり私はこの女の子と好きになっちゃってもしょうがないんだと
それだったら堂々と結婚した方が道徳的で
何罪を犯してないでしょうに
で いろいろケースが起きちゃうと
教会がもう彼のあの 葬式を取り消すんですよ
葬式取り消しても結婚するなよと
あんたはもう神の前でも独身でいることを約束したんだから
それは一生の約束だと
どういう話ですかね あれは
僕 神父になるということも神の前で約束で
それは取り消されますけど
結婚することを取り消されないと
もう馬鹿がいいところでしょうに
あれは単なるいじめ 単なる憎しみ
もう嫌だったら帰ってもいいよということだったら
いくらでも若者がもう神父さんになるでしょうに
そうするともう年 年 年でも教会でいろいろくだらんメサやってる中
音楽踊りやりながらいて
それなりに人格がね 良くなるでしょうに
宗教の世界だから それからやっぱり我慢できない
結婚しなくちゃと言って結婚したってもの
私はかつて神父でしたから
真面目に生活しなくちゃいけないということになるでしょう
それで人を助かるでしょうに
そんな姿勢ないんですよ
別に私はカトリック教じゃないんだけど
言う時は言います あんた方こうやればいいんじゃないかと
そうすると カトリックの信者さんに対してもすごくいいことでしょうに
意見をということは そういう人々に憎んで言うんじゃなくて
そういう人々をどうすれば豊かで幸せで幸福になるのかという考え方で言わなくちゃいけない
だから私の他宗教批判というのは
その宗教の人に面と向かって言う場合は結構受けますよ
もう全然宗教は勉強もしてない日本の一般の人々ですよ
まさに悪口を言うのは
なんで人の宗教の悪口を言うのかと
信仰してるとは言わないんですよ
だって私は怒りで憎しみで言ってる言ってないと
すぐわかるんですね これはもう自分たちのことを心配して
より幸せになってほしいんだから言うことであるとね
ですから この仏教の人でも誰の話聞いたってもいいんですよ
誰の話聞いたってもいいんです
誰々のところに勉強したってもいいんです
それは自由です 人間は
問題は聞く 聞くことは聞くんだけど
自分の人生の中に何が取り入れるのかと
自分がどのように自分の生きる道を調整するのかということが
自分にとっては絶対的な問題でしょうに
自分だから その場合の選択は自分でしなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで話は聞くんだけど
勉強もするんだけど 自分がその歩む場合は誰の言い方言い方学ぶのかというところでは
ちゃんと理性で判断しなくちゃいけないんです
その人は本当に 歩むべき真似るべき人格でしょうかと
その人の真似してよろしいでしょうかと
というところで判断しなくちゃいけないんですね
そうなってくると 仏教の人々には必要なものは全部お釈迦様がおっしゃってるんだから
誰にも口を出す隙間がなくなっちゃうんです
誘惑されていろいろ悪いことをさせても
そういう人々は それは私がだらしないんだからやってるんだって正しくはないんだと認めるんですよ
ブッダが間違ってるんじゃなくて
私が間違ってるんだと
だらしないんだと だからこんな悪いことをしているんだと
だから それででも我々ブッダに対する信仰は壊れないようにと大事にする
そこは微妙な あまりなかなか他の人にわからないことしたポイントなんですよ
で ずいぶん苦労するんだからね
ヨーロッパの方々はね
仏教の国はほんの 2つ 3
つしかないんですけど
潰そうと すごい金もかかるし
あらゆる工夫するんですけど
なかなか倒れないところとあるんですね
それで我々は頑固で人の話を聞かないと
教育も何もないよと 何でも侮辱したい放題侮辱するんです
仏教徒もするがすごいんだから
そう言われるとその通りに演じるんです
教育もあんた方は受けてないんじゃない
そうですね ではさせてあげる
ありがとうございます
ちゃんと教育やるつもり
宗教変わるかというと変わりません
損ばっかし イギリスやらアメリカ連れて行って
学費払って 面倒見てあげて
ちゃんと教育で これまた理性があるんだからうまくいくんです
勉強も 性格はいいんだから
どこでも雇う もうしょうがないんですよ
[沈黙]そういうことで
なんで変えられないかというと
言い方なんですよ ただ言っただけで聞かないんですよ
相手の人格は何なのかと
昔 私は聞いた話で 昔って言ったって子供の頃聞いた話で
そうするとすごい昔でしょうね
自分のお寺の版木の中にイギリス教会の教会もあります
ボロボロでもう信者さんがほとんど一人もいないと思いますけどね
そちら学校もあります
学校は結構まあそこら辺の自分の子供たちが行くんだから
まあ学校は一応それなりにまともに頑張ってます
で 教会もありまして それで子供の頃がその教会にある牧師がいたんですよ
その牧師がこの村人にもみんなにすごい尊敬をされている
尊敬されている理由は学者なんです
結構一流の それまたシンハラ語の国語のプロなんです
だからもうヨーロッパの文化を教育を受けて
もう英語しか喋れない人々なんですけど
シンハラ語のプロになったってことは
これは相当なもんなんです
シンハラ語ってのはものすごい難しいんですよ
私もプロじゃないんですよ
論書を書くときは もう私さえも自信がないんですよ
もうそんなこと言っちゃうと
もう若者は何言うかわからないんだからね
一応しっかり文法間違いなく書きますけど
あれ この場合はどうどうでしょうかというね
結構引っかかるとこある
これが分厚い文法の本も書いてるんです
この人は まあ私も勉強したことがあります
あのテキストも だから名前聞いただけで
私 あの先生こちら住んでるんでしょうかと
本のこと知ってるんだから
何人でしょうかという風に驚いちゃって
村人あれ その先生そちらにいるの？と
いるんだけど それはもう学者としてすごいんですよね
でもあいつはあまり気にすることはないと私に言うんですよ
あいつは あいつは別に気にする
そんな我々 そんなもう先生たちにすごい敬語使うんだからね
なんでそんな失礼なこと言うのかって
いえ まあ昔からね みんなこの大変な立派な人だって言うんだから
我々は昔そっちを行きましたよと
教会に この仏教の人々は
付き合うために その人もシンハラ語のプロだから
仏教のことも文化のことも何でも知ってるでしょうに
だから何とか教えてくれるでしょう
やって出してくれるでしょう
仏教の人も平気で行ってみた
行ってみたいんですよ
行っていたみたいです
そこである日 この村人と喋っている時は
何かカラスが来て その方が住んでいる家の前にごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ迷惑をしているんですね
我々にとってはもうカラスはいつでもいたずらするわ迷惑するわ
そんなのも慣れたもんで気にしないんです
来るともうわかるんだよ
あいつはもうこれからこれやるでしょうと
だからもう我々も狙ってる
カラスがいたずらしようすると邪魔してやるぞと
まあそこでお互い知恵比べでただ楽しいだけで
もう展示している干しているものはね
持っていくとかね 食べ物とかね
持っていったっていうのは悔やみやしないし
負けたっていうことで
カラスに カラスもそれ人間のことよく知っていて
まあちょこっと目が離せませんで
じっと待ってるんですね
隠れてればいいのに隠れてはいないんです
そこら辺にいるんです
いても取らない 俺に興味ないっていう感じで
それで人間も目線他のところへ行った途端
ちょこっと だって見えるところにいて食べるんですよ
なんかふざけてるんですよ
だからそれが結局我々にとっても楽しいんですよ
この人はカラスが来た途端
何のこともなく話をやめて
家の中に行って鉄砲を持ってきて
パチンとカラスを撃っちゃった
それだけで話してる信者さんが何も言わずにそのまま帰っちゃったんだと
挨拶もしないで もう礼もしないで
それっきり誰も行かなかった
だから何の教育もない村人たちの判断は
あの人は信頼できないんだと
頭が良かっただけではダメやと
だからあいつ言うことを聞く必要はないんだと
ただのカラスでしょうに
なんで殺すのか ちょっと手を振ってあっち行けと言ったら行くでしょうにと
そういう残酷な人っていうのはもう信頼できない
それっきり信者さん 自分たちの信者さんがいたならば教会に行っただろうと思いますけど
ほとんどもう一人いるか分からない
今は それで それはそういう昔話でね
もう私の十代の頃の話だからね
やっぱり微妙にこの物事を判断する角度はね
すごい微妙にあるんです
それは決して変な偏見じゃないんですよ
人格で人を判断する 行為で判断する
それは完璧に正しいわけないかもしれません
でも見えるところでしか判断できんでしょうに
すごい分厚い本を書いてるんだからといって
それだけではダメなんです
先に道徳やと 先に自分の日常の行いやと
それが正しければ あなたの話も聞くよというね
だからカトリック教の方々はいくら説教しても
すっごい金お金かかって苦労してもうまくいかないんですよ
向こうは酒飲みましょう
遊びましょう あれこれだからね
神様はなんでもやってくれるぞとか
道徳守りましょう 隣人を隣人を愛しますと言ったっても
仏教に勝てませんだからね
あんた何言ってるんですか？とね
やってますよと あんた方よりも立派にと
だからそれは話にならない
だからヨーロッパのあのだらしない文化
生き方を教えてやるぞということにしか攻撃道がないんです
そこでまたうまくいかないんです
だからこの そこはあまりもう学者にもわからないところでね
学者もいろいろ研究するんですけど
悪口ばっかり言うんですけどね
ミャンマー人がおかしいやとかね
自分もマスジードなのにもうなんでもう仏教のためにこんなお金かかってるのかとか
タイはどうでしょう あれこれとかね
悪口は言うんだけど 読めないところがあるんです
だから まあすごいこの他の文化の人にはそこは読めないんですよ
なんでこの頑固じゃない
頑固じゃないんですよ
微妙に理性を使ってるんです
はい まあそこまでまあ世間話でね
このエピソードと まあこの偈はね
まあそれほど関係あるわけでもないんですけど